la table du diable témoin de ce qui se
passe actuellement dans le sud un rocher
emblématique de la Martinique qui en
quelques années seulement a perdu une
grande partie de sa surface brisée par
les flous et c'est le même scénario pour
les falaises de la savane des
pétrifications inexorablement le temps
l'énergie déployée par la force des
vagues mènent à bien leur œuvre de
destruction on pouvait encore marcher
jusqu'au bout de cette falaise il y a
quelques années ce rocher était encore
rattaché à la terre il y avait au niveau
de la flore de la végétation et tout et
on voit en fait l'érosion de la falaise
donc c'est quand même assez assez rapide
en plus
[Musique]
on peut l’année on voit en fait
l'évolution quoi marcher au bord de ces
falaises c'est désormais interdit à tout
moment un rocher risque de se détacher
de la terre de s'effondrer en portant
avec lui tout ce qui se trouve à la
surface un balisage très simple prévient
du danger il est accompagné d'un arrêté
d'humeur qui interdite s'approcher du
bord dès le départ c'est indiqué et au
bord c'est indiqué aussi donc c'est bien
indiqué est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment dangereux
non après on se pose pas de question il
y a un panneau on sait pas approché
voilà après on va pas prendre un risque
non non mais rassurez-vous il vous sera
toujours possible d'utiliser ce sentier
de randonnée entre la baie des Anglais
et les salines le maire de Sainte-Anne
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer il estime
avoir fait son devoir de premier
magistrat en promulguant s'est arrêté et
que le travail de balisage appartient
également au service de l'État quant aux
falaises de la pointe des enfers elle
semble inexorablement livrée à leur sort
la mer dans quelques années devrait
avoir raison d'elle